je me souviens de mon premier mon
premier impossible j'avais 14 ans
j'étais seul à la maison et je regardais
l'épreuve du saut en hauteur des jeux
olympiques de munich
c'était l'épreuve féminine
il y avait des femmes c'était des
grandes j'avais 14 ans et la barre
montée je devais mesurer 1 m 75 la barre
monte à mettre 80 1 m 85 et il y avait
parmi les les athlètes outre bien sûr
les russes et les les bulgares et les
roumaines
il y avait une petite allemande 16 ans
elle n'avait aucune chance
trop jeune première compétition
internationale
son record n'était même pas le record
d'allemagne et voilà-t-il pas qu'on
arrive au mètre 90 et elle se retrouve
parmi les trois dernières et ce qui
était extraordinaire
c'est qu'alors que toutes les autres
compétitrices je ne me souvenais pas
d'avoir une compétition de son auteur
avant ça dans la vie toutes les autres
compétitrices sauter sur le ventre comme
c'était la norme à l'époque elle sautait
sur le dos je trouve ça extraordinaire
là bas remonte à 1 mètre 80 12
ceci à m 92 et elle sera la seule à
passer cette hauteur là j'étais fasciné
c'était le premier impossible de ma vie
le lendemain à mon école je me renseigne
ou est-ce qui est un club d'athlétisme
comme tous les gamins de bruxelles je
faisais du football et par chance mon
école était associé avec un grand club
d'athlétisme de bruxelles et j'ai
consacré vingt ans de ma vie entre
autres à m'amuser sur des sautoirs de
son auteur pour découvrir qu'elle était
là la magie de cet impossible s'est
lancé lancé un genou en l'air pour
passer sur son dos est retombé sur son
dos en fait j'avais eu mon premier
rendez vous avec l'impossible
cette révolution qui a été le fos
gorille le fait de sauter sur son dos a
permis une évolution extraordinaire du
record du monde du saut en hauteur
les femmes sont passées de 1 m 92
le record était stanier à un mètre 92
lorsqu on sautait sur le ventre est
monté à 2 mètres 9 et chez les hommes le
record qui était à deux mètres 29 est
passé à deux mètres quarante cinq essais
cette révolution conceptuelle qui est le
faux ce bris flop qui a permis cela j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser aux gens qui
faisait des choses extraordinaires qui
allait au-delà des limites et durant mes
études
et puis dans la vie professionnelle j'ai
toujours recherché des gens qui faisait
cela et puis je me suis dit comment est
ce qu'on peut comment est-ce qu'on peut
s'intéresser à à l'impossible je me suis
rendu compte que 2 1
il n'y a pas beaucoup de littérature il
y en a toujours pas beaucoup il y en
avait pas du tout à l'époque qu' il n'y
a pas de vraie vocabulaire pour parler
d'idées encore moins de d'un possible ou
de créativité méthodologie sur
l'impossible parce qu'il ya une méthode
est ce qu'il y à l'un ou l'autre grand
maître et je me suis lancé à tête perdue
depuis 20 ans dans cette quête de
l'impossible caisse est-ce qu'il a des
méthodes
est-ce que l'on peut accompagner les
gens dans leur envie d'un possible
est ce que j'ai envie de partager avec
vous ces quelques notions essentielles
qui vous permettrait d'aller plus loin
dans votre envie d'un possible de voir
partagée à la fois un vocabulaire
quelques notions clés qui permettent de
nommer les choses
première chose que j'ai que j'ai
développé parce que vous savez combien
il est difficile de parler d idée
d'aller voir son collègue d'aller voir
son patron d' aller voir son banquier
d'aller voir son conjoint et de lui
j'ai une idée comment est-ce qu'on
commence à en parler mais il faut
arriver à sérier les idées l'oreille un
premier type d'idée ce sont les idées
bleus les idées faciles à mettre en
oeuvre
les 10 et les idées vertes que nous
avons tous à longueur d'année sans nous
en rendre compte ce sont les idées qui
améliore tous pliés sous ce qui existe
puis à des idées plus plus compliqués
sont les idées en rupture les idées
radicalement nouvelle il fallait leur
donner un nom pour que l'on puisse en
parler et surtout pour qu'on puisse
commencer à les protéger pour que de
suite vous ne vous fassiez pas agresser
par rapport à ses idées ce sont les
idées rouge
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait des idées
impossible qu'est ce qu'on fait avec des
idées impossible fallait en parler aussi
et je leur ai donné de nom ce sont les
idées jaune parce que ce sont les idées
soleil ce sont les idées qui nous amène
en dehors de notre galaxie
ce sont les idées lointaines sont les
idées qui nous réchauffe et vous avez
vécu cela lorsque vous dites à quelqu'un
une idée qui est un peu un peu puissante
un peu forte hors du cadre de suite on
nous dit oui mais ça c'est impossible
et quel est votre défense comment
réagissez-vous part à sa grâce il
fallait inventer quelque chose et ma
démarche est inventé ce petit quelque
chose c'est le dragon le dragon comme
symbole de l'impossible il nous manque
un symbole pour parler de l'impossible
est de pouvoir dire à son chef à son
conjoint à son banquier vous savez ici
j'ai une idée je sais qu'elle est
impossible c'est mon dragon et comme
l'impossible est temporaire si nous
travaillons ensemble sur ce dragon si
nous savons en parler si nous avons la
méthode nous arriverons à le réaliser
parce que fondamentalement est ce si
elle le message clé que je voudrais vous
laisser aujourd'hui c'est que
l'impossible existent pour être remise
en question
il faut pas se laisser prendre de haut
par l'impossible il est hautain avec
nous il faut lui dire nous gagnerons le
destin de l'impossible est de devenir
réalité
un jour deux types l'impossible
le premier ce sont les les impossibles
opérationnel en impossible opérationnel
c'est c'est un objectif
un rêve une chose que vous souhaitez
réaliser dans votre vie
qu'on vous demande de réaliser dans
votre travail ou qui est une exigence
pour pour l'espèce humaine nous avons
beaucoup de l'impossible opérationnelles
de nos jours notre société et pour pour
l'espèce et pour la planète
donc ce sont des choses on se dit ça
nous le mettons à l'agenda pour le
réaliser donc ce sont des impossibles
d'action des impossibles du fer et accès
impossible là on a essentiellement à
faire à des obstacles et à des
obstructions et à des gens qui ne
veulent pas rentrer dans la démarche de
résistance
et puis un deuxième type l'impossible ce
sont les impossibles inspirational sont
d'un impossible extraordinaire
ce sont des impossible que l'on se donne
pour rêver ce sont des impossibles qui
sont là pour nous amener naturellement
hors du cadre
je vais vous donner un exemple prenons
un chercheur qui est spécialisé dans la
physique des matériaux
et il veut enrichir sa pensée il veut
sortir du cadre
eh bien il presse d'hier et si je
travaillais sur le développement de
matériaux qui permettrait d'avoir des
semelles de souliers qui nous
permettraient de marché sur le soleil la
probabilité que dans les 10 20 et 100 ou
1000 ans qui viennent un être humain
marchon le soleil est assez limité donc
on est hors du cadre
mais la provocation qu'amène cette
hypothèse de travail va amener notre
chercheur à imaginer des solutions
radicalement nouvelle donc ne négligez
pas ce type d'un possible lorsque vous
souhaitez penser autrement
il faut rechercher des impossible que
j'appelle aussi d impossible de
provocation donc les impossibles
opérationnels sont des impossibles pour
lequel on va se demander comment les
réaliser et les impossibles
inspirational ce sont ceux qui nous
servent à nous poser des pourquoi pas
et vous savez que l'expression pourquoi
pas est l'une des clés les plus
extraordinaires en matière de créativité
deuxième message c'est que l'impossible
est une frontière
moi je trouve que c'est extraordinaire
que l'homme a inventé deux choses comme
la question et l'impossible notre espèce
a inventé ces deux choses je vois que
mon chat n'a pas inventé le concept de
questions ni le concept d'un possible et
c'est l'impossible comme frontières nous
permet par rapport à ce que nous faisons
que nous soyons enseignants que nous
soyons chercheurs nous soyons femme ou
homme d'entreprise de déterminer quel
est le paramètre dans lequel nous
travaillons donc de faire une démarche
avec avec vos collègues avec les gens
avec lesquels vous avez des projets
d'établir quelles sont les frontières
les limites de l'impossible partagé est
extrêmement extrêmement riche parce que
c'est seulement à partir du moment où on
a établi la carte de l'impossible et
qu'elle est partagée qu'on va pouvoir
choisir les angles d'attaqué et se dire
où on va le faire tomber et mettre
ensemble son énergie s'il est une
frontière l'impossible est aussi une
création l'impossible apparaît très très
vite
je vais même presque toujours comme
quelque chose d'objectif
lorsque dans votre établissement le
directeur de l'informatique à votre
requête pour ajouter une fonction un
programme informatique réponse est
impossible ça tombe de très haut
ça tombe de très haut et bien en fait
l'impossible est une est une création de
chacun d'entre nous nous avons tous
créés dans notre vie dans nos activités
dans nos rêves des limites de
l'impossible j'ai deux couples d'amis
ils ont deux petits enfants chacun et
lorsque je veux
et dîner chez les premiers ils me disent
remarques de la chance de voyager comme
tu voyages nous on avait bien voyager
mais maintenant avec les deux petits on
ne peut plus et mes deux autres amis
lorsque je vais dîner chez eux ils me
parlent de leur dernier voyage plus
exotiques les uns que les autres
quand il fait les uns et les autres mais
ils se sont créés des frontières pour
certains avoir des petits enfants est un
frein définitif au voyage en terre
exotique et pour les autres c'est un
passeport universel pour faire des
rencontres extraordinaires
donc en fait par rapport à tout ce que
vous faites et par rapport aux gens et
qui vous travaillez l'impossible est une
est une création et cette création nous
pouvons comme elle nous appartient nous
pouvons la moduler la travailler et la
remettre en question il ne tient qu'à
vous de vous choisir vos propres vos
propres dragons de les mettre dans un
dans un lieu pour les faire grandir que
j'appelle une dragonne riz nous n'avons
pas de lieu dans les villes dans les
entreprises dans les laboratoires pour
parler de l'impossible quand vous avez
une idée impossible vous envoyez un mail
à votre boss et 8,1 très cher bosse je
sais plus j'ai eu une fantastique idée
impossible
en fait c'est presque impossible de
parler d'une idée impossible avec
beaucoup de gens dans des institutions
donc on a besoin d'une dragonne riz dans
un lieu où d'un espace où d'un moment où
l'impossible devient l'enjeu de
discussion évidente
vous avez demandé mais ce qu'il existe
deux méthodes willy à des méthodes
j'aurais simplement partager une une
avec vous il y a un il y à un designer
gallois qui s'appelle ross lovegrove que
j'apprécie énormément qui a comme
caractéristique lorsqu'il commence à
travailler avec un client d'abord de
l'écouté évidemment profondément
et puis de prendre congé de son client
et de lui dire je reprendrai contact
avec vous quand mon équipe qui est basé
à londres et moins nous aurons trouvé
des solutions impossible à votre
problème le client et enzo at oui
deviendrez vous présenter notre solution
impossible et je vous demanderais
si vous voulez apprendre comme point de
départ l'impossible pour comme enjeu de
créativité il part du principe et je
crois qu'il a raison que nous avons
presque réalisé tous les possibles
important qui était à portée de l'être
humain comme les grandes terres ont été
découverts les allées les continents ont
été découverts par les grands
navigateurs aux 15e et 16e siècles on a
pratiquement établi la carte des
possibles maintenant est celle la chance
de notre génération et des générations
qui viennent nous allons pouvoir
pleinement explorer les impossible donc
prenez la pose et elle prenait aussi de
temps à autre la posture et de se dire
tiens dans tel projet si au lieu de
commencer à voir comment on pourrait le
faire avec ce qu'on sait faire
si on partait par une solution qui nous
semble impossible
on peut se dire vous avez entendu parler
probablement de ceux de ce projet
français un des problèmes des éoliennes
pour un certain nombre de gens c'est
qu'elles sont géante qu'est le gâche
pour certains de très beaux paysages
donc si elles sont géante et bien
résolvant le problème
faisons des toutes petites et quelqu'un
s'est dit pourquoi pas faire des
éoliennes de la taille d'un arbre
évidemment les spécialistes on dire mais
on a besoin de grands espaces et on a
besoin pour récolter le vent d'immenses
pâle et bien c'est un l'étape
expérimentale
ces arbres avant qu'ils peuvent récolter
dans votre jardin qui peuvent récolter
dans votre jardin
le vent et il parait t'il un arbre de ce
type là permet d'alimenter une maison
familiale en électricité sans aucun
problème j'ai pas si vous êtes déjà
interrogé sur le vrai pouvoir de
l'impossible
quel est son vrai pouvoir qu'est ce qui
nous importe ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'il nous transforme pour peu
qu'on l'a mis à son agenda
parce que ça c'est la condition quoique
énormément parmi vous y incarnez à idées
mais combien d'entre vous note les idées
impossible dans ce carnet et combien
d'entre vous ont incarné à un possible
combien d'entre vous organise des
réunions impossible dans les
organisations dont ils sont est ce que
pour ceux qui travaillent dans des
entreprises
est ce qu'il y ait une ligne budgétaire
consacrée à l'impossible je ne connais
aucune entreprise qui est une ligne
budgétaire consacrée à l'impossible
alors que faire concrètement trois
choses le joueur aux commandes
la première c'est d'écouter vos dragon
on me demande souvent c'est quoi une
grande idée surtout les américains eux
et ils rêvent toujours de big bear la
grosse idée
la grande idée c'est très simple une
pique à dire c'est une toute petite idée
en qui quelqu'un a eu confiance et ce
petit dragon il a pris dans ses mains et
la protéger il a montré à quelqu'un de
bienveillant tu as vu ce que j'ai trouvé
ah oui c'est quoi ça tu sais on peut en
parler à intel et avec courage et
passion ils ont eu confiance dans cette
idée ici on est un peu d'argent ils y
ont mis du temps ils y ont mis de
l'engagement donc écouter vos dragon et
oser exprimer et utilisé l'expression
tiens j'ai un dragon et je voudrais en
parler
deuxièmement mettez le à votre agenda
dans votre agenda regardez combien de
temps vous avez passé au cours dès le
trimestre le semestre se termine au
cours des six premiers mois de l'année
combien de temps vous avez passé
à travailler sur de l'impossible
l'impossible ne se réalise que si il est
à l'agenda
et troisièmement ce que je voudrais
c'est vous proposait de créer des
dragonnes riz qui lit des lieux partout
où les gens peuvent être fiers de leur
impossible et partager mesdames et
messieurs l'impossible existent pour
être remise en question
vous êtes venus ici parce que vous avez
partagé l'idée que l'impossible devient
accessible
vous avez envie de devenir des
conquérants de c'est impossible et je
suis très fier d'avoir introduit les
conquérant de l'impossible que tedx
grenoble a invité pour vous inspirer et
vous permettre d'aller là où personne
n'a jamais été et que l'impossible
mesdames et messieurs est temporaire
merci